here's the truth sometimes even the best
of us get brain block but there's a very
simple process that you need to follow
to get out of that right and create the
best architecture you possibly can
what's going on guys my name's David
tomich I'm a registered architect here
in Western Australia and today I'm going
to walk you through a process of
unblocking your brain to be able to
actually articulate your ideas as best
as possible I'm going to do that by
showing you one example of when this
happened to me so let's start with the
simple facts first of all I had an arcad
model up running live you can see that
to the side of me in a time lapse the
silent question was beautiful it
overlooked the water it had Contours
left right and center and it was
surrounded by the natural Bush and
vegetation now I love these sites but
for most people it is extremely
challenging when I visited the site for
me it was going to be so simple so easy
to understand I had this Vision in my
head of how the house was going to come
together exactly where you're going to
drive in how the two streets were going
to work in your favor and how the
overall concept was going to come
together now what I didn't realize is
that as soon as I dived into this design
I'd fail I'd fail miserably I'd fail
horribly and it would take me about 10
times longer than I'd ever expect to get
this design out of my head properly onto
paper why did this happen well first of
all I dived way too quickly into the
d-pad and just forgot about all the
architectural Basics this happens when
you have an idea and you just run with
it sometimes it works out sometimes it
doesn't and in this case it really
didn't and I wanted to articulate that
clearly because most of the time in my
videos I'm able to produce a design so
easily without any flaws and just work
through it like it takes me an hour it's
not always the case and sometimes we do
get brain blocked even when we're so
experienced and know exactly what we're
doing so originally I thought that this
was going to be a single story design
absolutely beautiful Drive In on the
side street and Tuck the car underneath
I thought it was going to work
incredibly well but then it just started
to fall apart and I couldn't get past
this idea whatsoever I kept coming back
to the idea the garage has to be here
the house has to be here and I just
couldn't get out of the cycle so first
of all what I had to do was stop take a
complete break walk away from the
computer and come back to it later I
understand this isn't a luxury that we
all have but sometimes it is something
that we have to do so for me that
actually meant turning the whole
computer off going away and coming back
the next day to tackle it fresh
sometimes 30 minutes or an hour is more
than enough just to reset your brain and
get back into this activity properly
other times you do need the day so take
what you need to be able to get back
into this process without actually
taking too long where it starts becoming
a burden to think about this project
again so the first attempt was a huge
fail it was nowhere near what I wanted
to be and it just didn't work so what I
needed to do was come back it's absolute
Basics once I was able to reset that
meant for me scrapping the whole design
scrapping it starting again not even
having it on the side to reference I
didn't want to think about it because it
didn't work so push that aside delete it
re-map out the entire site I went back
to site I visited it I stayed there for
a little while and I understood the
environment a lot better understanding
the environment is critical because it
allows you to get those architectural
design details correct and get those
ideas flowing once again I then remap
The Contours of this site as best as
possible with a lot more detail to
understand the street fell away the site
flowed on multiple Contours and levels
and you needed to think about that all
in one context before moving on I then
physically mapped sunrise sunset midday
the prevailing winds and the streets
themselves I looked at where the
neighbors were the context of the
neighbors and just your basic General
Studies this is something that
traditionally you're able to walk on
site when you're experienced have a
quick look around and go yep I know
exactly what I'm doing but sometimes you
definitely need to go back to that
graduate level very basic Bare Bones
architecture and just get your brain
working and activated once again we're
thinking about all these ideas all these
Concepts we're dragging this and this
and putting it together to create this
beautiful idea and conceptual image but
then it falls apart so when you bring
break it down bring it back to Bare
Bones Basics and understand why you're
trying to actually achieve these things
it becomes a lot easier to achieve them
now like I said brain block can carry
through for a whole project this project
had four five six attempts I can't even
remember how many times I went back to
the drawing board rearranged the whole
floor plan gutted it started again after
the second attempt where I thought okay
now it's starting to make a little bit
of sense I'm getting the flow of this
project a little bit more
I still ended up scrapping it once more
and starting again but what I did after
attempt number two was take that project
out of arcad and slow my whole brain and
my whole process down slowing the
process becomes critical when brain
block occurs because all you're trying
to do is fight fight against this brain
block and push through it which doesn't
work you can't just you can't take the
wrong puzzle piece and keep trying to
put it into the same slot it's never
gonna work you have to go back take that
puzzle piece aside find the right one
and place it in the right space so by
slowing your brain down it allows your
brain to catch up and go that's the
wrong puzzle piece let's find the right
one for me that's all about taking it
back into 2D and taking it away from the
computer taking your workspace to a
different environment and slowing it
down it's about taking the floor plan
from arcad to morfolio print it out
whatever and going back to the physical
2D process sketching over the plans
breaking it down drawing circles and
squares and lines and boxes that mean
absolutely nothing and take two seconds
to erase it's so easy to move lines
change lines erase them scribble over
them ditch a whole concept Start A New
Concept overlay Masters and masses of
Trace paper just to make ideas work and
get them out of your brain once you've
completed this process the brain has
slowed and you've gotten a plethora of
new ideas that you can take back into
arcad and then remodel reevaluate and
repeat the process funny thing is with
brain block once your brain actually
unblocks it starts to flood so after
attempt number four I had sketched it
out and re-imported it and deleted it
I'd repeated the process so many times
over I'd found where the garage Works
how the actual property works and then
all of a sudden I was sitting down in
bed one day and just went huh that
doesn't work that's not what this
project is about so I went back out on
site re-understood the context re
understood the views the vistas and how
that property and that design was going
to work the bones were there it just
needed fine tuning and once that brain
unblocked that fine tuning became easy
and so self-explanatory so I wanted this
architecture to open to the landscape I
wanted to open to the view and be
connected as much as possible with the
current design the corners the curves
the actual context it just didn't work
yes you could open it up but you could
open up on a very cheap level it wasn't
the architectural expression I was
looking for so that meant going back
again scrapping some of those elements
that I thought were critical and the
best part of the design refining them
refining them again and then finally
coming to an architectural process that
truly worked for this specific client
this specific site and this specific
project now don't get me wrong even
after five attempts this project isn't
perfect it's going to need a hell of a
lot more work to actually get somewhere
where it is worth presenting to a client
the brain block still isn't finished
it's still going to take me probably
another week of just mapping out this
project going through it time and time
again to get it right where I think it's
worth presenting so let's recap if you
have brain block as an architect and you
want to get out of it first of all take
a break take five minutes an hour a day
step away from the computer and then
come back let your brain naturally reset
if you're still having trouble then map
out the basics go back to graduate level
understanding think about the paths the
prevailing winds the Sun the cross
ventilation think about it all think
about that site and context place and
character then think about it in space
2D 3D sections elevations really take it
down to the Bare Bones Basics after that
if your brain's still working too fast
you're unable to push past that brain
block you're unable to see that you're
putting in the wrong puzzle piece slow
down take a step back take it out of our
CAD bring it into 2D it doesn't matter
if you can't draw it doesn't matter if
you don't know how to draw taking it
into 2D slows the process down and it
helps you see that it's the wrong puzzle
piece that you need to slow down find
the right answer and then move forward
the final step that actually adds
significant value is getting peer input
it doesn't matter if that peer is a
professional peer or just a person or a
friend getting an outside perspective
opens your brain to new ideas that you
haven't thought about or may have
thought about but just completely
dismissed so a secondary opinion is
critical in architectural design and
it's a very collaborative field so never
feel afraid to ask a colleague or friend
for support for help and to be able to
get you out of this brain block if you
don't have anybody like that in your
life you're welcome to join our Discord
group it's completely free the link is
down in the description below I and you
can simply upload your plans onto the
Discord chat ask for some help and some
feedback and somebody from the community
or even myself will help you try get
through that brain block anyway that's
all for me today guys thank you so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed the
video I hope you enjoyed the time lapse
that was to the side of me and I hope
this process allows you to slow down and
break through your brain block however
like I said that is all for me so like
always I'll see you next Monday